Ça me rappelle autre...
Autres expressions, autres mots.
Bonjour, ici c'est Steve Kaufman
et je veux vous parler bien sûr
de l'apprentissage des langues
mais surtout de
l'importance de l'oubli...
dans l'apprentissage
des mots et des langues.
Si vous aimez mes vidéos,
veuillez vous inscrire.
Cliquez sur la cloche
pour avoir des notifications.
Et si vous me suivez
sur un service Podcast
Veuillez laisser un commentaire.
Je l'apprécie beaucoup.
Bon.
Souvent, j'entends des gens qui me
disent "J'ai une mauvaise mémoire"
"J'ai de la difficulté à
apprendre des langues"
"Je n'ai pas le talent pour
l'apprentissage des langues"
Et moi, je dis toujours,
l'apprentissage des langues.
c'est une question
d'acquérir des habitudes
et ce n'est pas une
question ni de talent...
Il se peut qu'il y ait
des différences de talent
mais ce n'est pas ça la
chose la plus importante
mais c'est de vouloir
s'exposer à la langue
et ne pas trop se préoccuper
des choses qu'on oublie.
Et qu'en effet, l'oubli c'est une partie
très importante de l'apprentissage
et parce que...
Inévitablement, on va oublier
tout ce qu'on apprend,
on va l'oublier
et on va le réapprendre et
ensuite, encore une fois, l'oublier.
Et il y a des recherches qui
ont été faites en Californie
Un professeur, Robert
Bjork, qui démontre que...
Notre mémoire consiste
non seulement en des choses
dont on peut se rappeler, qu'on
peut aller chercher dans un contexte
quand on est en train de discuter,
quand on lit quelque chose.
Mais la mémoire, ça consiste aussi
en ce que lui il appelle la "Réserve"
c'est à dire des choses qu'on a
su ou qu'on a vu et qu'on a écouté
et qui sont entrées
dans notre mémoire
mais qu'on n'est pas capable
d'aller les retrouver, les chercher.
"to retrieve them"
comme on dit en anglais.
Mais ce sont quand même des choses
qui font partie de notre mémoire.
Et dans l'apprentissage des langues,
c'est les choses qu'on oublie.
Et souvent, comme a
dit Proust ,des choses qu'on...
Peut être des fois des choses
désagréables ou des choses
où on ne fait pas d'efforts
exprès pour s'en souvenir.
Ce sont ces choses là dont on va
se rappeler à un certain moment.
Et même moi,
j'ai eu l'expérience
parce que je suis en train
de préparer un discours
que je vais donner à des
avocats qui vont en Ukraine.
Et je vais présenter
cette présentation
sur l'apprentissage des langues
et d'ailleurs en ukrainien et en anglais.
Alors j'ai décidé d'un
peu rafraîchir mon ukrainien
et j'ai étudié donc les mini histoires
qu'on a à LingQ et en se faisant...
j'ai vu que, même en réapprenant des mots
assez communs de hautes fréquences
ça me rappelle autres
expression, autres mots.
Donc ça stimulait à fouiller
dans ce qu'il y avait de mémoire
disons directe là, de mots
que j'étais en train de réapprendre.
Il y a d'autres mots
que je ne lisais pas
que je n'entendais pas, que je
n'écoutais pas et qui ont réapparu
Donc, c'était à dire,
la réserve qu'on crée
chaque fois qu'on
écoute, qu'on lit
même si on oublie le mot,
on oublie l'expression.
Ce sont des choses qui
vont dans notre mémoire
et c'est en oubliant les mots et les
expressions, qu'on augmente la réserve.
Et c'est de ces mots
là, éventuellement
qu'on va finalement créer un vocabulaire
important qui va nous permettre
d'avoir des conversations
intéressantes avec des personnes
comprendre des livres, et cetera
et dans le système
LingQ notamment.
Je me suis rendu compte que puisque la
première fois qu'on rencontre un mot à LingQ
il est souligné en bleu et
ensuite on le converti en LingQ.
Donc en couleur jaune,
mais tous les mots en jaune...
C'est des mots dont on
ne peut pas se rappeler.
Parce que les mots qu'on comprend
dans un contexte, n'importe le quel.
C'est des mots su.
Alors si je regarde
mes statistiques
dans différentes langues
que j'ai étudié sur LingQ
Eh bien...
en ce qui concerne par exemple
l'ukrainien, j'ai à peu près 60.000 mots su
et en fait moins de mots
jaunes, c'est à dire des mots
qui font partie de ma réserve
parce que c'est une langue...
où j'ai beaucoup écouté, beaucoup lu
et même l'étude du russe ou du tchèque
m'ont beaucoup aidé à reconnaître
des mots dans l'étude de l'ukrainien.
Par contre, si je regarde mes
statistiques en arabe ou en persan.
Bah, Il y a trois fois plus
de mots dans ma réserve
c'est à dire des mots que
j'ai rencontrés, que j'ai lus
que j'ai cherché et
ensuite que j'ai oublié.
C'est trois fois plus
que les mots que j'ai su
que je peux reconnaître
dans un contexte.
Dans le cas de l'arabe, j'ai à peu près
60.000 ou même davantage de mots
que je suis allé chercher
dans le dictionnaire.
Je les ai mis dans
ma base de données.
Ça fait partie de ma réserve
mais je ne peux reconnaître que
20.000 de ces mots là, donc un tiers.
Le cas du persan est semblable.
J'ai à peu près 30.000
mots que j'ai sauvegardés
qui sont dans ma base de données
et font partie donc de ma réserve.
Mais je n'ai que 12.000 mots su
c'est à dire que chaque fois que
je les vois, je les comprends
et c'est tout à fait
bien ça, c'est normal.
Et finalement, si je continue
finalement j'aurais davantage
de mots que je peux utiliser.
Mais l'important là, c'est
qu'il ne faut pas trop exiger
qu'on puisse tout de suite se
rappeler des mots qu'on a étudié.
Il faut accepter l'oubli,
l'oubli créateur
Le fait que toutes ces
activités d'écoute et de lecture
et en voyant des mots, en écoutant
des mots et des expressions
ça fait croître notre, disons...
faciliter nos habitudes linguistiques
avec cette nouvelle langue.
Et ça a fait croître
aussi notre réserve.
Donc, même si on a
l'impression de ne pas progresser
parce qu'on n'est plus
dans ce stage de débutants
où il y a tellement de mots à haute
fréquence qu'on les apprend assez vite.
Maintenant, on est dans ce
qu'on appelle le plateau.
Alors là, il faut bien se rendre
compte qu'en lisant, en écoutant
en faisant croître sa réserve,
on crée les conditions.
Donc, c'est à dire en oubliant
les mots, on crée les conditions
qui vont nous permettre d'atteindre
un niveau, disons dans la langue
le niveau qu'on veut de pouvoir
parler la langue couramment.
Eh bien, voilà ce que
je voulais dire à ce sujet
et je vais laissé quelques vidéos
que j'ai fait sur ce sujet de la mémoire.
En ce qui concerne
l'apprentissage des langues.
Merci! Au revoir.